do you see a world where
like in your sense in your own work and
just in the space industry in general do
you see that people are moving towards
bigger satellites or smaller satellites
is there going to be a mix like what's
and what are we talking
what does it mean for satellite to be
big most and small
what's that so big the space industry
prior to i don't know 1990
you know i guess the bulk of the
majority of satellites were
the size of a school bus and cost
a couple billion dollars and now
you know our first launches were on um
satellites the size of shoe boxes that
were built by high school students so
that's a very different
you know to give you the two ends of the
spectrum
um big satellites will i think they're
here to stay at least as far as i can
see into the future
for things like broadcasting
you want to be able to you know
broadcast to as many
people as possible there
you also can't just go to small
satellites um
and say moore's law for things like
optics so if you have an
an aperture on your satellite you know
that just that doesn't follow moore's
law that's
that's different so it's always going to
be the size that it will be
you know unless there's some new physics
that comes out that i'm not aware of
but if you need a resolution and you're
at an altitude that kind of sets your
size of your telescope um but
because of moore's law we we are able to
do
a lot more with smaller packages and and
with that
you know comes more affordability and
opening up access to space to more and
more people
well what's the smallest satellite
you've seen go up there like what
what are the smallest kind you said shoe
boxes yeah so
i think you know the smallest their
smallest
common form factor can fit a softball
inside
so that's 10 centimeters on each side
um but then there are some companies
working on
you know fractions of that even and
they're doing things like
um iot type application so it's very low
you know bandwidth
um type things but they're finding some
niches for those do you mean like
there's a business there's a thing to do
with them
yes what do you do with a small
satellite like that
um you can you know track a ship going
across the ocean as like if you need to
if
you're just pinging something you know
you can handle that that amount of data
um and those latencies and so you have
to have propulsion on that you have to
have a little engine
no those are just you know letting fall
out of the sky
um okay yeah but what uh so what kind of
solid lights
would you equip a colloid engine on
anything that's bigger than
probably about 20 kilograms um anything
that needs to stay up for more than
a year or anything somebody spent more
than like 100k
to build are kind of the ways i would
think about it that's a lot of use cases
what's this what's the small set like
what what's category it's actually
very big i think it's like 700 kilograms
or
keep hitting my microphone um maybe a
thousand kilograms
down to 200 kilograms or
people have their own kind of
definitions of how they break them up
but small
sat is still quite large and then
it's kind of also applied as a blanket
term for anything that's not a school
bus size satellite
we need to get our jargon straight
industry
so what do you see do you see a possible
future where
you know there's a few thousand
satellites up there now a couple of
thousands of them functioning
do you see a future where there's like
millions of satellites up
up in orbit or if we get millions tens
of thousands
which just seems like the natural
trajectory of the way
things are going now is going tens of
thousands yes
the two you know buckets of applications
one is
imaging and the other is communication
so imaging uh i think that will
plateau because one
satellite or one constellation can take
an image or a video and sell it to
you know infinity customers but if
you're
providing communications like broadband
internet or satellite cell or something
like that
satellite phone um you know you're
you're limited by your
transponders and and so on so to serve
more people you actually need more
satellites and and perhaps at the rate
you know our data consumption
and things are going these days um yeah
i can see tens of thousands of
satellites
you